estamos de regreso para actualizar la
información económica en france 24 junto
a nuestro compañero nuestro colega luis
méndez ur ix muy buenas noches lo hice
una vez más crece la preocupación por lo
que es la crisis global en la cadena de
suministro verdad así es una situación
que se está viviendo de maneras
distintas en diversas partes del mundo
pero que está impactando el proceso de
recuperación económica y muchos países
tras los daños provocados por la
pandemia hay que recordar que la casa
blanca anunció el día de ayer el haber
participado en negociaciones para
extender las operaciones en los puertos
de los ángeles y long beach a 24 horas
siete días a la semana la crisis en la
cadena de suministro se presenta luego
de un alto consumo en diversas partes
del mundo que tomó a las fábricas como
un proceso de recuperación tras la
pandemia en reino unido debido a la
situación se teme que se vea afectada a
la temporada de ventas navideñas
escuchemos lo que dijo el canciller
sobre el tema
lo que está claro es que muchos países
de todo el mundo están experimentando
desafíos en la cadena de suministro al
igual que nosotros pero estos desafíos
son de naturaleza global por lo que no
podremos solucionar todos los problemas
pero estoy seguro que habrá una buena
provisión de bienes para todos y estamos
trabajando para eliminar los bloqueos
donde podamos bueno louis emparejado a
lo que es esta crisis de suministro que
también nos describía en mucha
preocupación por lo que son los precios
de los combustibles y de la energía en
europa una situación que se viene
presentando santiago desde los primeros
días del mes de octubre y que preocupa
por la cercanía con la temporada de
invierno respecto a los combustibles el
precio de esta semana tuvo una media de
un euro y 46 centavos esto marca máximos
desde septiembre del año 2013 no
obstante a la par de los precios
elevados de combustible los de la
energía también vienen representando un
problema para las sociedades europeas y
gran parte del mundo ya que ha generado
temor por la cercanía que el invierno de
acuerdo con la publicación española el
país este viernes la nación alcanzará el
valor de 231 con 82 euros el megavatio
hora siendo este el segundo valor más
elevado tras los 288 53 que se
estableció hace una semana bueno les
hablemos ahora de la situación que se
está viviendo en turquía porque se
depreció la moneda del país y de acuerdo
con medios de ese país el desplome
marcaría mínimos históricos y oxy lo
entre 9,5 y 10,6 libras por dólar en la
jornada de acuerdo con medios como
reuters y efe la situación fue impulsada
por la medida del presidente de recep
tayyip erdogán de destituir por decreto
2 gobernador vice gobernadores del banco
central la moneda turca estaba
presentando presión a la baja luego que
el ente emisor redujera los tipos de
interés de 19 el 18 por ciento el pasado
mes bueno hay noticias de américa
latina' el gobierno de cuba anunció su
pronóstico de crecimiento cual es baja
revisaron a la baja de acuerdo a lo
señalado por alejandro el ministro
economía de ese país y estima un
crecimiento de 2 por ciento para este
año de acuerdo con el representante
gubernamental la nación se ha visto
afectada entre otras cosas por la
pandemia la escasez de oferta y las
sanciones de eeuu
y vio una contracción en su economía
durante el año 2020 de 11% y estimaban
un crecimiento mayor al 2% anunciado
para este año el turismo una de sus
principales fuentes de ingresos estuvo
restringido durante el pasado año por
ello esperan que la apertura de
fronteras que prevén para el 15 de
noviembre impulse la entrada de divisas
escuchando entonces no creo realmente
que podamos alcanzar el 6 por ciento del
crecimiento que está en la meta del plan
de este año nosotros estamos aspirando a
movernos al entorno de un 2 por ciento
de crecimiento este año seguimos con más
noticias de américa latina' leyes pero
vamos ahora hasta chile donde hubo una
suba en la tasa de interés hacia el
fuego anunció el banco central de este
jueves que dio a conocer un alza de 125
puntos bases con ello la nueva tasa de
referencia se ubica en 2 75 por ciento
siendo el mayor incremento en la
historia del organismo luego que el
mercado estimaron ar se alza entre el 75
y 700 puntos pases la noticia se
presenta en medio de la inflación que se
ubicó en 1,2 por ciento en el mes de
septiembre y las conversaciones para la
aprobación de un cuarto retiro del 10
por ciento de los fondos de pensiones
viajamos rápido hasta china donde se
inauguró la feria de importación y
exportación que también es conocida como
la feria de cantón famosísima y es que
el mini el primer ministro de ese país
li kequian destacó el compromiso de su
país para facilitar la apertura y el
libre comercio durante el presente año
la economía china ha sido una de que ha
mostrado mayor recuperación y por ello
le ha manifestado que el país cuenta con
una fuerte resistencia y capacidad para
cumplir sus metas económicas y que dicen
los indicadores louis cerraron con
números positivos sobre todo en eeuu
donde wall street pudo dejar atrás el
nerviosismo que existía en los días
previos también hubo números positivos
en europa y al mercado asiático abrió al
alza el día de hoy les me decirles
muchísimas gracias hasta aquí la
información económica en france 24
siguen informando se en el resto de
nuestra programación
[Música]